welcome to part two of our inaugural G
gfell Town Hall once again we're joined
by fans from around our beautiful
country including the cheers Squad from
Northern State Community
[Music]
College yeah and really excited and Back
Again of course our friends from the
Eastern State Correctional
[Applause]
Facility great great great great
gr gr okay tonight's guest really knows
how to shake things up especially when
he sticks it to the media just by by
show of
hands who here is willing to admit that
the Trump Russia collusion
hoax was indeed incorrectly reported by
the mainstream media wouldn't be
approprate question like that why not
why would that be inappropriate I think
it would be inappro what's inappropriate
is lying to the public by show of hands
was the Wuhan lab the likely origin of
the covid-19 pandemic everybody meia or
not does anyone here agree that the
hunterbiden laptop story as reported by
the New York Post was indeed accurately
reported and was not Russian
disinformation but was in fact a
factually owned laptop of how to buy yes
talk about flipping the script but
what's his obsession with raising hands
let's ask him please welcome back to the
show GOP Presidential candidate v r
oh my
God we got more great questions so let's
get right to it Boseman asks VI I like
you and if you're not going to be
selected as our general president
presidential candidate will you agree to
a VP
selection well I I uh appreciate that
I'm by the way talking to you from a gas
station in Western Iowa in the middle of
a blizzard where we pulled over so just
to provide some context here where we
are
we kept all of our campaign events but
ding you know yeah I figured wanted to
dress the elephant in the room
there hello from the gas station
hey can you give me a 2 L bottle of
fanta thank you Greg you know I would
actually take the Dr Pepper man I always
had you as a Dr Pepper guy but uh but
you know we we'll bring that back next
time in studio and you know the truth is
to address boseman's question I have a
thing called independent opinions which
has historically been a disqualifying
feature for vice president but when it
comes to my ability to lead this country
I think I'm best position to do it from
the front I do think we need a leader
with fresh legs I think from the Next
Generation to reach and lead the next
generation of Americans and I'm in this
to at once take our America First agenda
to the next level but also reunite this
country in the process and I think it's
possible to do both of those things at
the same time I don't think securing the
southern border or using our military On
the Border or shutting down large
numbers of federal agencies I don't
think that's a leftwing or a right-wing
idea I think that's an American idea but
some of my policies are sufficiently
let's just say unconventional and go the
distance that I don't think I can do
that in a number two seat and that's why
I expect and hope and and ask you to
help me become the next president of the
United States you know I'm think I'm
just wondering if the people that are
working there think that you're crazy
who's this guy
who's the guy in Isle
6 running for
president how did he did he get out of
the nearby mental hospital so this is a
great question uh lad KC asks how will
you free the j6 protesters and stop this
insane persecution and will you appoint
Greg as your press
secretary that's you know I I have a
good job but uh let's talk about Jan 6
what would you do yeah
so I've said this I'm the only candidate
to make this Pledge on day one in office
I will pardon every peaceful protester
that day because that's the right thing
to do for this country and I will go
further Case by case and understand even
those who were allegedly violently
charged to understand if the facts
actually match up and if they had any
constitutional due process rights denied
and anybody who was held to a different
standard of the rule of law will get a
pardon because that's how we actually
have to stand for one standard of the
rule of law in this country
antifa and BLM burned this country down
in cities across this nation for a year
and yet peaceful protesters that day the
likes of Owen Shroyer who just had a
megaphone didn't enter the capital
yelled
1776 ended up serving in prison that's
not America and I also think that there
are some more facts that still need yet
to come to light here I know you're not
supposed to talk about that but I think
it's the hard truth hard questions about
Capital police officers who let people
into the capital I don't think that
entrapment ever should be the basis a
capital police officer waved somebody in
I don't think that that's appropriate to
then arrest that same person and that's
what I'm going to stand for as the next
president great
point from Alabama my home if you become
president what are the first things
you'll do to improve school systems our
education system what would you
do so look let me start it's sad that I
have to start at this level of Basics
but even when I was in Iowa over the
last week there was another school
shooting here
one thing I've said and this is top of
mind is shut down the Department of
Education and put three armed security
guards in every school across this
country so at least we know our schools
are at least safe and protected for our
children next is actually focus on
achievement get rid of the teachers
unions in the public schools and school
choice actually levels up not just the
private schools but the public schools
in those same areas teachers unions if
you end them they can then compete with
private schools and I think the teachers
who do the best job as measured by the
achievement of their students should
actually make more money than they do
today so bring some Merit to the
compensation of teachers to lift up the
achievement of our students and then
let's get rid of the indoctrination and
that's why I've said I'm not going to
reform the Department of Education I'm
going to get in there and shut it down
and return 80 billion to parents and
teachers and public school districts and
private school opportunities throughout
this country that's what it means to
actually stand for an educational system
that's about our students rather than
about a bunch of teachers union
bureaucrats and that's how I'm going to
leave I got
uh about 40 seconds left it and related
this is what another viewer asked will
you unwoke our military and how would
you do that
yes so a few things on our military
clean house at the Pentagon and the Dei
even the boxes they check Hispanic
American black American white American
no eliminate all that there's one box if
you join our military it is American
that's what unites the people in the
military on common purpose
and Mission and here's the other thing
thank you one more thing on the
military anybody who lost their position
in the military because they refused to
take the covid vaccine will have their
position reinstated with back pay times
one and a half we got to clean up our
military and actually respect the young
men and women who serve that's what it
means to have a real commander-in Chief
in this country V great job thank you
for doing this at the gas station you
came on a full tank talk to you later
great job thank you thank you guyses hot
takes on Ron's handshake hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else